please welcome this year's bronze war 2
winner lubomir coke Scott you know and I
never thought anything like this would
ever happen but I have been practicing
speeches since I was about eight just in
case first of all I'd like to thank my
father he has taught me everything I
know he is my mentor and I listen to you
even when you think I don't mom I love
you my grandfather is no longer with us
but it is his life and his story that
sparked this film to me he was the body
meant of wisdom and he will always be my
inspiration I would like to thank
everybody that contributed to the film
my actors which doctors Allah Allah and
chiffon chef adak alaska threes Mamai DP
Kevin erhard the editor board Sebastiano
the composer my co-producers Mira trees
moba and valtor oolong and everybody
that contributed to the film and made it
what it is now I hope all of you feel as
happy and excited as I do right now I
would also like to thank everybody that
encouraged me along the way my
professors my girlfriend and her family
I would also like to thank slovakia
which is round from in case you can't
tell it is a great country to be from
and also like to thank the Savannah
College of Art and Design which is an
amazing school to study film finally I
would like to thank the academy for
reminding us that people do watch our
films and that they do care I feel like
this is just the beginning hopefully to
something great and now is the time to
start working harder than ever at least
for me and
so let's make films